[Music]
in big energy news submitted by Jay Paul
from Canada the phrase big dick energy
is going viral after ariana grande
tweets about her new fiance Pete
Davidson's big dick no I just said Oh
who's Pete Davidson
he's fellow cast members Oh they
recently announced that they're engaged
after only dating for a few weeks what
it must be true love oh that's a lot of
you person it's gonna last forever she
she always forever would look like the
12 year old putting on makeup she's
still hot though
oh no hot is the word ya wouldn't call
her she doesn't look like a kid to me
she looks like a child
cute pretty pretty cute she just looks
super like early 20s she's cute she's
pretty she's beautiful I wouldn't call
it hot I wouldn't like she's no she's a
very beautiful young lady but she just
looks like a kid who wears makeup
to me that's what all like a like her
she has too much of a baby face yeah
she's like if you notice cuz recently
she's been wearing these dresses wear it
like so like the dress just covers like
up here and then from down from her
boobs it's like a big like a little girl
dress I can teach you and then she'll
wear like these super high like like
knee highs thank you I couldn't think of
it and so it's like a little girl mix it
like sexy woman oh that's her thing yeah
cuz I see this if this literally looks
like the kids that are out there on
YouTube doing to make old is she 18
thank you no she's older than that 23:25
all grown woman oh happy birthday happy
birthday Ariana her age I think she
looks early to one yeah she looks good I
think she's yeah I think y'all think I
don't think she looks like she's 14 yeah
she doesn't look like that yeah she used
to yeah she used to until she first came
out when ricky shucks came on I was like
oh she's a little girl and he's like no
you got to see her recently and then we
looked up and I'm like oh [__] okay
she has an album coming out called Luke
Davidson called funny guy day know if
they get a call like sweetener sweetened
or something and so she tweeted out that
there was gonna be an interlude
dedicated to him and so someone said how
long is Pete oh as in the interlude not
as in anyway and she said like ten
inches oh [__] I mean like a little over
a minute that's what she deleted the
tweet oh but what if that was a joke
it is a joke before she like really
really really really blew up she was
funny like I followed her she was really
really clever last time and then she got
really famous a she has two cents
herself got a PR team now to let her
know why she's handicapped she was like
Marlon Wayans I used to love him on
Twitter oh that's the love Marlon Wayans
but like on Twitter he was just he was
such an [__] he would just roast all
of his friends like they'd the funniest
[__] and then now all gone he doesn't
say anything negative anymore he's
probably trying to come out the movie or
TV show yeah he would clown on like
Kevin Hart like Terry Crews anybody I
remember that yeah I would be tears
laughing oh [__] I'm pretty sensitive
but I enjoy funny things you're
sensitive
oh yeah what stuff rubs you the wrong
way oh not the wrong way I'm sensitive
to funny things like I said from SNL Oh
24 years old Oh older he's super
racially ambiguous SNL cast member zahle
are you black no he's actually ohyou
like the youngest youngest Oh cuz I
heard the SNL like qualification process
very strenuous you got to be funny ass
butt and you're getting your guests for
like the longest that's dull thank you
what a talented young man yeah super
talented
yeah so then good job dude one tweeted
out this would you like to read it
Pete Davidson there's six three with
dark circles exudes big dick energy
looks evil but apparently as an angel
and loves his girl publicly the only
thing worried wrong with him is that
he's a good is he a Scorpio but anyway
I'd married him with
month to who's that [__] authority knows
that's my knowledge but she's at the
horny at Twitter girl this just went
viral baby Viacom it started the whole
big dick energy oh man she took it from
someone else
I see from a long time ago yeah now it's
really viral and this is the tweet that
started it all and so now there's all
these tweets about people who have big
dick energy or for example this this big
dicks aren't kind of like a battery like
it just has a lot of falters inside so
that suite here says big dick energy is
confidence without cockiness it is never
misplaced and it cannot be stimulated it
is a sexual equivalent of writing a
check for $10,000 knowing you got it in
the bank account thank you for attending
my TEDx silence so yeah I just try to
have a plug at the end
no dick energy is we should have more
big dick energy in this world that's
very attractive girls love big dick
energy they don't really care about a
big dick all these what the energy of a
big day yes confidence yeah like for
example she went on Jimmy cut you're
saved
yeah because I can give big dick energy
doesn't mean that big dick yeah it's
like a it's like the spirit of a big day
but it doesn't have to be a big we know
you guys don't have 10-inch dicks we
know I don't want one I don't want all
the blood that's what the little dick
people I only need a little little dick
people say I don't want a big day I only
needed one more inch to be 10 but I'm
still close man that's so true
I don't want one what you do the tables
to her I want a perfect dick I would
wear short shorts all the time I want a
chameleon dick I would just swing around
because like all girls are different
pipe sizes so it's like whoever you
really really like you want to be able
to fit cuz it'll be a tragedy if you
really really really love them and then
you're like you're [__] it's like
[__] a tunnel
I want to burst them and I'm like oh I'm
gonna just I'm gonna you know what if
you got a big ass [__]
I want a big-ass dick but if you got a
little ass [__] oh no little ass dick
you to fit the luck yeah if you have a
little [__] on a rip
okay it's not gonna be fun for both of
you though
I'm not ripped just to let you guys know
only one inch away from whipping you
yeah well yeah so Pete Davidson he
recently went on Jimmy Fallon and during
his and Robert Pattinson was there and
so a good chunk of his interview was not
even about Pete himself he would just
kept throwing it to Robert Pattinson and
how how much he loves his movie good
time he even pulled up a clip of a good
time which this movie is already like
out who did it was doing that Jimmy
Fallon was doing that no no Pete day
walk okay
yeah so like this is just big dick
energy that he has like he has so much
confidence that he's just like yeah just
like we don't even need to talk about me
let's just talk about Robert Pattinson
like that's kind of the thing so his big
dick Energy's just nervous
no because he's trying to pass the torch
no cuz I'm like Jimmy was like no you
had your in a movie like what so about
your movie he's like yeah I mean it's
great it's awesome it's cool but no you
got a chick a good time though his
public publicist in the backstage is
like his delivery too and then he kept
cursing here just saying well I was like
a normal person like normal person okay
but a lot of people are just saying like
but that's like everybody reads into a
lot of things that just normal he's not
like a normal good dude okay you might
sound like a normal dude but he's really
relatable and really popular in a lot of
exactly normal stuff all others exactly
what a normal duties yeah the world is
changing he's just hating I'm not hating
I'm saying it I think that that's what
this article is saying like they're just
highlighting a good normal person that's
not what I was you know this to what I'm
saying what I'm saying is like they're
making something a lot bigger than it
actually is you know what I mean so this
fingers which I'm kind of glad that
thing is popular right now so now
they're like highlighting his regular
stuff that he's read I'm glad I'm glad
they're doing that because it's so rare
within his industry that now people are
gonna be like oh that's the trend [__] I
want to be relatable do you know what
cuz you know what they're used to
I got this new movie coming out and it's
awesome yes their use of that [__]
acting as [__] no one talks like
that yeah or if it's like that like
they're super cocky and they're just
like not even trying to be a normal
person whenever they're interviewed yeah
I mean what the last time you guys saw a
late-night show everybody's like that I
so I'm saying like I live I love Jimmy
Fallon i watch these things everybody's
like that it's super casual casual it's
not like that anymore so I'm saying like
from somebody who watches interviews
anybody you watched like any kind of big
star they come on they're just normal
people that's what that's what's great
about these late-night shows they're not
out there going like hey I'm super cool
nobody ever does that so maybe the
article writer it just doesn't watch
late-night shows and then there was the
first guy and they were like this guy's
out but hey if you watch any of like
like Conan O'Brien stuff that's why Cohn
is so great the people just have a
casual conversation it's [__] funny
as hell so I was like so I don't see
like the the thing about it I don't know
maybe I'm tripping maybe I'm just being
a hater I'm not being able I liked if he
gave us in he's [__] the youngest no
cast member oh yeah so then uh when
Jimmy kept trying to congratulate him
about his engagement he's like thanks
thanks but it's just so weird like why
do people care like cool Thanks he's
just like rushing in on me I really like
how things are changing right now though
cuz Hollywood's kind of forced to be
more human and real because people are
sick of that [__] yeah they just
want to see real [__] like what's going
on here on jakie news instead of [__]
[__] like that but when I see that
stuff to it I find it really hard to
watch when they're fake no cuz I know
what goes on behind the scenes so I know
it's prepped they know what they're
gonna say but I like I mean I'll watch
it for like the the construction of
everything like how it all comes
together and it's like oh yeah yes so
they made this work and it made it seem
natural when they knew they were prepped
with the questions yeah no one you know
so I like watching a lot more IG stories
than like scrolling through IG and I do
follow the cardassia's I follow Kim and
like I was just watching her story and
she was showing like what's the girl the
blond girl Martha Stewart
so it was Chloe's birthday and she's
just walking so she was just
instagramming like Oh Chloe's like
birthday party or whatever and you know
she had Chloe and her baby daddy I guess
cuz I don't think they're married which
one's Chloe the big girl yeah the big
girl with the blonde hair oh yeah the
one that there was a scandal with a
Lamar Odom before yes yes yes so then he
happens to be at that party and then
Kim's like oh um do you think this guy's
gonna block me and I guess like there
was that whole thing where they it was
that scandal and I guess he blah I don't
know the full story but just her being
real about it and kind of just joking
around about it I was like oh this is
why people like you because you just you
know I mean you're hot like you're rich
and then you have like this this
personality and like you're kind of a
little bit real like it seems like she's
been more real now so as I was watching
I was like oh that's pretty cool that
she's just kind of joking around about
all the scandals and all this [__]
that it could be the the reality show
it's the most human version of a
celebrity that you get because I they
make stupid like that
lot of stupid conversations just like I
don't want this person I want this
person can maybe that's relatable that's
why people like you yeah that's a lot of
articles say about the Kardashians that
their number one talent is relatability
with their fans could they make them
feel like they're best friends yeah
they're don't good I'm pretty good at it
I need that skill yeah they're pretty
good at it cut a lot of people laugh
with me off they're laughing at me and
half the times a little bit of both man
yeah I think that's why people like
cardi B because I when I first saw her I
was like okay and then I saw her - I
have video clips of her as a person
now I like a music it's like hard not to
like her she's not really a fascist up
[Music]